اهلا بكم في خطاب تاريخيه القاها امام
الكونغرس الامريكيه بمجلسيه هكذا الرئيس
الاوكرانيه فلوديمير زيليننسكي ان
المساعدات الامريكيه لكيف ليست صدقه بل هي
استثمار في الامن العالمي والديمقراطيه
وان اوكرانيا تديرها باكثر الطرق مسؤوليه
وخرج الاسكي مخاطبا المشرعين الامريكيين
اود ان اشكركم جزيل الشكر عن المساعده
الماليه التي قدمتموها لنا والتي قد
تقررونا تقديمها لاحقا
وبعد 300 يوم على بدء الحرب الاوكرانيه
الروسيه استقبل زيننسكي استقبال الابطال
في اول رحله له الى الخارج وسط اجراءات
امنيه استثنائيه واستمرت الزياره ساعات
قليله وعده خلالها الرئيس الامريكي
جوبايدن بمساعده ماليه جديده وللمره
الاولى بنظام الدفاع الجوي باتل روسيا
بالمقابل اعتبر زياره تزيلنسكي الى واشنطن
90 تسعيدا واضحا تحمل في طياتها مؤشرات
عده كما عبر الكرملين عن السياحه من تسليم
اسلحه امريكيه جديده الى اوكرانيا مؤكده
ان ذلك فاطمه الصراع وصفه الخطوه
بالمواجهه العسكريه الغربيه غير مباشره
مستبعدا بذلك اي فرصه لمحادثه سلام
جري جري
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
ينضم الينا هنا في الاستديو قسطنطينيه
الباحث في العلاقات الدوليه اهلا بك وايضا
من موسكو ينضم الينا تيمور دويدار الخبير
في قطاع الاعمال والعلاقات الدوليه اهلا
بك سيد تيمور ليبدا اولا هنا في الاستديو
مع السيد قسطنطين هذه الزياره
مباشره
وهو يرفض ذلك وانه استثمار كيف ذلك
يعتبرها ساذهب بسبب ان السلاح الذي كان
يقدم قبل كان يقدم دون دون اي مقابل وفقا
يعني وثائق الرسميه لكن في الحقيقه
اوكرانيا في 10 اشهر الاخيره اسوا اصبحت
رمزا لحوريه داخل اوروبا وفي العالم
الخارجي ولذلك الدعم الولايات المتحده
وشركاء الغربيين لاوكرانيا اصبح امرا
حيويا همم لديمقراطيه في اوروبا لحوريه
واستقلال اوروبا لان اذا نتذكر همم ختابات
بوتين وختابات التسريحات المسؤولين قبل
بدايه الحرب الاهداف المعلنه او شبه
المعلنه كانت همم
ضم همم حتى الدول الاوروبيه الشرقيه
فلذلك اوكرانيا اصبحت معقلا لي حوريا
وديموقراطيه والام في اوروبا فلذلك يجب
على اوروبيين والامريكان اثمار للحفاظ على
استثمار في اوكرانيا عن طريق السلاح
باعتبار ان اوكرانيا ستكون حائط صد
لاوروبا اللا يتغلغل النفوذ الروسي همم
بالتاكيد اوكرانيا اذا اذا اذا سقطت همم
بالتاكيد روسيا كانت قد
البولندا او سلوفاكيا ودول البلتيك كانت
هناك خطوه خطوه واضحه ولا ذلك ولكن همم
همم بفضل الجهود الاوكرانيه والصمود الشعب
الاوكراني والجيش المعارك ما زالت تتم في
اوكرانيا وستستمر فيها حتى حتى النهايه
اذا الى موسكو تيمور دويدار الخبيره في
قطاع الاعمال والعلاقات الدوليه سيتمور
يعني اوكرانيا تعتبره استثمار وليس صدقه
هذا السلاح الذي يقدم لها موسكو كيف تنظر
له هل هو بالفعل استثمار ام هو استغلال
كما تراه موسكو بانه حرب الوكاله مثلا
يعني على مدار 30 عن بعد تفكر الاتحاد
السوفيتي اوكرانيا تستخدم
روسيا
يعني في السياسه الغربيه
لا يعني لا شكوك في ذلك تماما
بخصوص الحرب الوكاله بالطبع هي الحرب
بالوكاله منذ فتره طويله للغايه
من واشنطن بالتحديد فام يعني اي شيء جديد
لا يعني هذه الاستثمار انسحب تعبير
معلم بقى
حتى الاغذيه في الاعتبار تلك الماساه التي
تحدث
للشعب الاوكراني اه سوف تطيل امد هذه
المعاناه يعني المقاومه سوف
اه تظل هي سوف تكون اقل فاقل انا روسيا
حتى الان لم تدخل اي حرب ولكن ولكن الغرب
وحتى زر المسكي يراه استثمارا لانهم
سيكونون في مواجهه ذلك الماده الروسي الذي
يريد ابتلاع كل المنطقه
يعني استمعت
للضيفك وانت الان تردد نفس الكلام ما قاله
ضيفي
وهذا واجب شوف هناك كان في همم تعليه سقف
الطلبات من موسكو همم
قبل بدايه هذه العمليه العسكريه الغرب همم
بحرف الاطلسي الى حدود ما قبل 1997 فمم
همم هذا سقف طلبات لكن انا لا اعتقد ان
احدا في الكريمرن بذلك الغباء لكي يقوم
بهجوم على احد الدول بنحالف الاطلسي
ويعرض روسيا لمثل تلك المغامره همم
فلا يوجد اي تهديد لاوروبا من قبل روسيا
ولم يكون هناك انما حجما المعاملات قبل ما
حتى بعض 2014
لا تهديد الاوكرانيا بينما هناك حرب
انا متكلم باللغه الروسيه وانا لغه روسيه
هذا لغه امي انا من
من الناس من المواطنين اوكرانيا منتكلمين
بالروسيه الذي الذين جاءوا لحمايتهم لا
نحتاج هذه المساعدات ولا حمايه لكن انا
اشاهد الوسائل الاعلام الروسيه بشكل دوري
وانا اتذكر الرسائل التي قد ارسلتها همم
القنوات المتعدده
ومسؤولين متعددين من
الصحفيين يعني موظفين الحكومه كانت هناك
كانت هناك تصريحات همم يعني خطه ضم اوروبا
بتلميحات الا ذلك واضحه حتى في خطاب
التيمور قبل بدايه الحرب ولم تكون هناك اي
اهداف معلنه هذا هذا صحيح فلذلك عات همم
البوتين ومسؤوليه يعني مجال للمناورات همم
في تصريحات
يعني الى محور الثاني ماذا لديك تعليق على
ما تحدث به ضيفه
لا ادري ماذا اقول اهو انا اساله
يعني اذا كان يتحدث عن التلفاز والاعلام
والربع جامده هذا الشيء لكن هو يقول
مسؤولين من من المسؤولين اذكر لي اثنين يا
سيدي التي تتحدث بالروسيه هي توجد تركيا
هو يقول لك طيب خليني انتقل الى هل تريد
الاجابه عليه هناك
نتحدث عن ما تحدث
اتكلم اولا عن ان الصحفيين همم وسائل
الاعلام والشبكات التواصل الاجتماعي لم لم
تكن هناك اي اهداف معلنه كما قلت من اي
مسؤول روسي حتى من في في خطاب رئيس
البوتين لم تكون هناك اي اهداف واضحه
فلذلك همم يمكن استخدام هذا الكلام لماذا
ذهب الان في هذا التوقيت
هناك هدفين تم اعلانهم تجريد اوكرانيا من
السلاح هذا رقم واحد
ورقم اثنين تجريد اوكرانيا من الفكر
النازي فقط هذا هذا هذا ما كان سبب في
الحرب من وجهه النظر روسيه سنعود اليها
لكن دعنا نعود الى موضوعنا السيد قسطنطين
لماذا ذهب الانذالنسكي الى واشنطن ما
اسباب هذه الزياره
هي ليست سياحه وليست شكر فقط
هناك عده اسباب انه في الايام المقبله
سيتم اتخاذ القرار بخصوص ميزانيه مساعدات
الامريكيه لاوكرانيا لسنه همم
بمقدار تقريبا 45 مليار دولار
وبسبب تصريحات متناقضه خاصه من همم طب
الحزب الجمهوري
انا اعتقد انه سيرياسكي تاخذ قرار بزياره
الشخصيه لتاثير على يعني حزبين بوجوده
الشخصي ثانيا هناك الشيعيات وبيانات
الاستطلاعات انه روسيا تخطط هجوما جديدا
في
فبراير يناير او فبراير المقبل فلذلك
اوكرانيا تحتاج لزياده من للمزيد من
الاسلحه والموسات الغربيه في اسرع وقت
ممكن
فاعتقد ان كانت هناك يعني كثير من
التشورات الاضافيه في هذا ولكن هذه تيمور
يعني اليوم همم بالحديث موسكو كيف تنظر
الى هذه الزياره الولايات المتحده الان
ستسلم اسلحه دفاعيه هل تراها ان المواجهه
قد تصبح مواجهه اقرب ما بين الطرفين بدل
الاوكرانت تصبح مع الولايات المتحده
باعتبارها داخل هذه الحرب ام الى الان
اوكرانيا الان تحارب تقريبا يعني معظم
اسلحتها همم مثل الغربيه او حلف الارض
افندم
اسلحتها غربيه كما نعلم ولكن ماذا ستفعل
روسيا حيا الا ذلك
الاستمرار يعني
ماذا تتوقع لن يكون لك اولا بخصوص الهجوم
المتوقع لا توجد حتى الان همم لدينا اي
نوعيات همم من الشفافيه يعني لا توجد اي
معطيات ل همم لذلك لان لا توجد قدرات حتى
الان همم
حشدت لفعل ذلك
هذا من ناحيه
يعني المناورات في بلا روسيا او حتى زياره
مدريد الى الصين هل لا ينبع عن حدوث اي
شيء
يعني التركيز الاساسي عسكريا الان
والسياسيا
اخذ اخر مناطق من دانيت
او جمهوريه الدنيا
وانتهى الموضوع لكن في بعد هذه الزياره ان
سميناها همم
الاداره الحاليه لروسيا في اتخاذ قرار همم
ليس بالساهل وهو
اجتياح الاعلان الحرب على اوكرانيا
واقتراح
اجتياح اوكرانيا لان
خيرسون هل هي قادر على هذا الاشتياح
روسيا انسحبت من مدينه خرسون لكن مش مش من
مقاطعه خرسانه طيب همم وان راينا الخارطه
سوف نلاحظ همم ذلك الانسحاب كان باراده
روسيه ليست دفعه اوكرانيا
الان الان المعركه في بخمتها وبالتالي همم
يعني قد نرى هذه التطورات يعني المجال
ايضا لضيفي هنا ماذا ستفعل همم كيف احيانا
هذه المناورات الروسيه في بيلاروسيا
التحركات ايضا هذه الزياره هل ستنعكس على
ميزان القوه على الارض خاصه انه واشنطن
همم تقول بان همم موسكو تستخدم الشتاء
سلاحا ايضا في هذه الحرب
اه نعم المنورات القوات الروسيه في بيضه
روسيا ليست اول مره
فكانت تستخدم ارض بروسيا وحدود الاوكرانيا
البيلروسيه لشني الهجوم الاولي في شهر
فبراير
فمهما كانت خطه الروسيه وجود القوات
الروسيه داخل بيلاروسيا ااه تمنع الاكواد
الالكترونيه من تنقيل كيف يتحدث عن اشتياق
قد يحدث ذلك اجتياح روسي من بلاروسيا
يمكن يمكن
احتماليه ان هذا يحدث ولكن
ستكون المخلصه
هناك السيناريوهات المختلفه على قياده
الاخرانيه عن همم تحسب للجميع
السيناريوهات انه يمكن انه هذه المناورات
مجرد همم
وايه يعني تنقيل ال- الانتباه ال- ال-
القوات الاوكرانيه او ممكن همم تجهيزات
للهجوم الحقيقي طيب سيد تيمور اذا تكرمت
باختصار تعليق اخير من قبل قبلك
يعني هذه الامور سنه
بيلاروسيا هناك 9000 جندي روسي في
بيلاروسيا فل ده حتى للحديث عن ذلك
الامر بسيط للغايه همم سيد زيانسكي مع غفر
الاحترام لا هو طريقه لقاء وهو
ههه في الكنيست اقصد الكونجرس الامريكي
همم يجب عليها ان يعتني بشعبه الاول دون
ان يبكي عند الامريكان فالحياء الحل عنده
طاوله المفاوضات الاعتراف
وبالطبع شبه جزيره الكرم ووقف هذه الماساه
لا اعلم اذا كنت تطلب المستحيل بالنسبه
للاوكرانين خلال حديثهم يعني كانوا حتى
يرفضون القلب ان يعترفوا بها روسيه
طيب شكرا جزيلا لضيفي من موسكو تيمور
دويدار الخبير في قطاع الاعمال والعلاقات
الدوليه الشكر ايضا هنا لضيفي في الاستديو
قسطنطينيه الباحث في العلاقات الدوليه
شكرا جزيلا لكما
بانوراما مستمره وفيها ايضا
ثلاث هجمات التنظيم المتطرفي في اسبوع
لماذا نشطت داعش في العراق مؤخرا وهل هي
عوده للتنظيم ام ضعف شعبيه
وسيطره الدوله